democratic candidate joe biden has won
the u.s
presidential election after sealing
victory in the battleground state of
pennsylvania
major u.s tv networks and the associated
press have called the race in his favor
the 20 electoral votes abide in one in
pennsylvania
have allowed him to surpass the 270
votes
needed to win the election according to
projections by the associated press
he has received 284 electoral votes
to republican president donald trump's
214.
well joining me in the studio is stacy
bivens from the dws
election team stacey now it's official
joe biden is president of the united
states
what can we expect to come next well
let's just all try to take it in for a
moment this is very exciting
and we've been waiting for several days
to get a result but let's
make no mistake this has been a historic
run
joe biden seemed like an unlikely
candidate he was the oldest
in the field of democrats the oh and
extremely white and old and people were
like oh we don't want this
we want something new and progressive
but here he is
who it the man who fits the moment the
man who's been talking about
unity bringing the country together
engaging in the international community
he's the man for the moment and we've
seen an end to the to the negative
rhetoric and the purposeful division
of the country this is where we're
headed that's right you say he's an
unlikely candidate but in many ways he
was also
kind of seen as a democratic insider
going into this race
and it felt in some ways like we were
almost seeing a repeat of 2016 where the
polls had him really firmly ahead
in the days coming up to this election
as they had for hillary clinton back
then
we're expecting to see perhaps a
landslide repudiation of donald trump's
presidency
but we're now four days after the
election it really came down to the wire
didn't it
yeah i mean it just goes to show a
couple of things first of all the nation
is
very divided these two candidates donald
trump and
president-elect joe biden could not be
more diametrically opposed
and you know donald trump got what 70
70 million votes donald um and joe biden
74 million so
it was close and so now it's up to joe
biden
as president to bring everyone together
and now we get to see how he goes about
doing that
i mean yes people like to make
comparisons to 2016
but let's be clear when trump
was running against hillary clinton both
of them had extremely
low favorability people like joe biden
and so he's going to have to use his
character people voted for that
and run to stay true to his platform to
move the country forward
so do you think that that likeability as
you call it is going to be something
that will allow
him allow him to reach across the aisle
to republicans and to trump voters
you know who very badly wanted to see
donald trump win this election and
become president for a second term
we see we'll see i hope so i think that
character matters and the fact that he
donald trump made fun of joe biden this
whole election talking about how he's
been
in congress for 40 years but you make
connections with people and most people
on either side of the aisle say that joe
biden is a man who
he stands by his word he's a man of
strong character and strong conviction
and part of reaching out to other people
and advancing agendas
is being somebody that people can trust
i don't think most people trusted donald
trump he was able to bully his way
to get and threaten people in order to
get his way
but he didn't really connect with people
on the other side of the aisle and this
is something that joe biden
has promised that he will do and
throughout his entire career
if passed his prologue this is something
that is part of who he is
so yeah and i think it is fair to say
that the country is more divided than
we've ever seen um i want to get some
reaction from the united states
and bring in our correspondent sumi
somaskanda who is standing by for us in
washington d.c
uh sumi what is the latest where you are
in washington
well as stacy said this really is an
historic moment you know over the last
few days this excruciatingly
weight if you will for for the outcome
here a decisive outcome
uh we've been kind of inching towards
this moment of being able to officially
call joe biden
president-elect the 46th president of
the u.s and also to call
kamala harris the vice president-elect
let's not forget her in this she would
be she's now the
first uh black woman to take this
position
and what got us here over the last uh
day or two is that we have been watching
these vote tallies in the state of
pennsylvania
and just before uh this this was called
for joe biden we saw that that
tally for his lead in the state of
pennsylvania
went up to around 30 000 votes and what
that tells us is that
he has definitively won this election
that president trump
essentially cannot catch up to that lead
in that state and so the reactions you
see here
is on one hand already some relief if
you look at some of the uh
the the the comments on twitter so far
and also
anticipation because we don't know what
we're going to hear from president trump
he is not at the white house right now i
should say he headed out earlier in the
morning to virginia to his golf course
where he is at the moment
and so we are waiting to see his
reaction but um
the the right-wing media outlet here fox
news has also from what i've seen
call this election for joe biden so
it'll be very interesting to see
what the first reactions are from
president trump just this morning
uh he was again casting doubt upon uh
mail-in voting so we'll have to see
what we hear from him now assuming you
say he's been casting
doubt upon the mail in voting that's
something he's been doing for the months
leading up to the election
uh and something that became
increasingly clear as those mail-in
votes were tallied and it appeared to
increasingly favor joe biden in those
crucial swing states
on election night itself the situation
appeared to heavily favor
president trump as the early votes were
coming in why have those states now
tipped to president biden
president-elect biden let's say
right this all right claire this all
comes down to how
uh people voted the way that they voted
this year because of the pandemic we saw
a record number of people cast their
ballots by mail so
ahead of the election in a state like
pennsylvania the one that we're focusing
on right now that has been decisive
in this outcome we saw a number of
people cast their ballots by mail and
the majority of those were democrats and
the reason for that is quite clear joe
biden and his team
encouraged his supporters to go out and
cast her ballots in any way that they
felt was safe and secure in this
pandemic
on the other hand on election day
november 3rd we saw this rush of people
go to the polls to vote in person and
the majority of those voters
were republicans and there president
trump had repeatedly said
in the lead-up to this election that he
believed mail-in voting is fraudulent
and so the majority of supporters did
not want to cast their ballots that way
and that is why in the key battleground
states like again pennsylvania on
election night it looked like
those votes that were cast in person
that day as they were tallied that
president trump was in the lead
pennsylvania was a state where election
workers could not actually
open the envelopes to those mail-in
ballots until election day and start
counting
and with so many mail-in ballots having
arrived it took them some time to count
them
and that is why it looked at first like
president trump was in the lead
and then joe biden caught up and then
overtook him
and this is what president trump has
been claiming has
is fraud but there is no proof of that
at all this is simply
the legally uh lawfully allotted votes
that have been cast that are now being
counted that clearly show
that joe biden is clearly in the leading
as one
all right sami samaskanda thank you very
much for that analysis we'll be coming
back to you
throughout the evening for more analysis
i'm sure but i want to cross now
to pennsylvania that key state that has
tipped it in favor of
joe biden to our correspondent stefan
simons who is standing by
stefan what's the mood like there
well i'm standing right in front of the
building where it actually happened this
is where it happens this is where the
last batch of about three and a half
thousand
those words were released they were
counted they were put in the system and
that
put joe biden statistically here because
this is math this is statistics
over the top why all the networks did
call biden as now president-elect
because there is a trajectory
they say which clearly shows that biden
naps about 80 to 85
percent in this city in this county here
philadelphia county
and that puts him undeniably over the
top because trump
even if he wins 50 60 of any other vote
coming in now
cannot win it he can not keep up the
numbers so
there you go president-elect now joe
biden the 46th president of the united
states
what happened here as we set up this
location
and got ready for our live shot here
cars are driving by right and left
they film us we film them and they're
honks celebratory honking all around
town
so to speak and this is where we are
right now
all right stefan you've been there for a
few days on the ground in addition to
that celebratory honking
have you had a chance to talk to voters
there about how they expected
this vote to turn out
yeah in the last few days this was not a
divided town it was
the larger crowds were clearly a
pro count dagger they get the honking
live television for you
um one second
all right so that'll sink in
[Music]
a little bit that makes it makes you
understanding you and talking to you a
little bit easier if they pass on a
little bit
anyhow so we talked to a lot of people
in those last few days of course and the
overwhelming
majority of them were expecting clearly
expecting that biden pulls through here
with this mailing ballot vote um there's
still a few thousand votes to be counted
those are
uh provisionary votes and those are
those uh votes my colleagues from cnn
called
problem child votes they call them like
this here really
um a wrong signature on the wrong
envelope or something a little wrong
with this they will be still counted
it's not that they are stopping now just
because uh networks and agencies called
joe biden as next president-elect but
again
statistically he's over the top he made
it
uh trump has no chance of of of uh uh
winning this anymore um even if he gets
arizona
or any other state now it's over it's
done
and uh people here were quite quite
secure in their opinion and
in their take of that this is will be
the outcome of course there were
the trump supporters who are actually
scheduled to have a
uh a protest now in harrisburg the
capital of philadelphia starting in five
minutes
a steal the vote anti-org against steal
the vote protest
let's see how this will turn out and
stefan what else can we expect as today
progresses in addition to those protests
you just mentioned
uh i think we will also see more
celebrations beyond honking
um uh here in philadelphia and maybe in
other cities in
in pennsylvania too there i don't think
that the trump supporters or the the
trump clientele
and base will stop protesting and making
their voices heard
here harrisburg anywhere else probably
um but you will also expect and have to
expect more
data released again just because we are
now
saying the next president of the united
states will be joe biden number 46
in the historic account and
president-elect joe biden now
over the top that doesn't mean that
those states here
and those counties here in pennsylvania
here in philadelphia but also
georgia will go into a recount as we
know uh this will still happen
arizona will be still counted nevada and
so on all those states which were not
called or are not called yet and are
still busy accounting they will release
data
throughout the day throughout the next
few days and so will philadelphia do
this too
all right stephen simon's there for us
in pennsylvania that key state
that has just tipped the election in
favor of joe biden to become
the next president of the united states
i'm gonna cross now over
to our dw correspondent oliver zalet who
is at
uh in wilmington delaware which is the
hometown of joe biden
oliver great to see you there what has
the reaction been from the biden team
well there's so much celebration here uh
unfolding as we speak we're here at
joe biden's headquarters and the people
have been waiting here for days for this
very moment and of course joe biden
himself
is the third time he ran for president
he will be the oldest president in
american history
but of course it's now clear that he won
this election we're waiting
for a big celebration here tonight
fireworks are set up
there is going to be a victory speech
delivered by joe biden
but that said nevertheless there's also
a lot of problems joe biden and harris
were
nearing record numbers of the corona
virus crisis there are lots of reforms
to be done
in this country and it's not even clear
if joe biden can of course crucial
so celebration on the one hand side but
a lot of lots of questions also to be
answered
as we're moving on with the remaining
votes for the senate
oliver that's true as you say i think
that senate race perhaps hasn't had as
much international attention because the
presidential election is so complicated
to begin with the democrats had been
hoping to win it back to make it easier
for president-elect joe biden to get his
policies through congress
be that on climate change be that on
immigration and it's not looking
like it's going to go in that direction
she said we're going to see joe biden
come out tonight
what can we expect him to say in his
victory speech
well he will certainly try to be the
unifier that's what he's promised to be
that's what he ran for
in the first place and we will hear a
completely different tone
than from donald trump who was
essentially feeding off division
and of hatred that he spread during his
presidency and now you see
cars coming in here you hear them
honking as well so honking all over the
place here in joe biden's
hometown of wilmington well then later
tonight he will certainly repeat parts
of what we already heard yesterday that
was not a victory speech per se
but he also tried already to outline his
policy goals which is of course as you
mentioned climate change
it's education it's health care so a lot
of big big goals that he said for
himself but again
it's crucial to see whether or not he
will be able to move on
with those or if he has to rely on
executive orders just as many presidents
before him did
including of course donald trump and
barack obama
now oliver there are of course a few
months left between this election
and when joe biden will actually take
office in january
what do you expect we will see in these
coming months from donald trump
as he know that he has as he knows that
he's been voted out as the sitting
president and joe biden is waiting to
take over that role
there's there are of course countless
lawsuits and as you know the trump
campaign
is alleging that there was a wide fraud
in this election
but again we have to say and stress time
and time again that these
allegations and claims are considered
baseless that's confirmed by
international election observers
nevertheless donald trump will try to
move it to the court he threatened to go
to the supreme court
his his team is coming out with lots of
fake stories right now
even some of the conspiracy movement of
q anon
it's really questionable whether or not
that this all will resonate with the
courts
uh in order to be able to reach the
supreme court he will go through the
federal courts first and he might even
be rejected at that level so it's very
a lot of questions are there but he's
certainly also trying to win time
uh on the 8th of december this will be
the next crucial deadline set in this
election process because this is when
the states actually
have to announce uh their electoral
college and how many
college votes they will have that's
right there has been a lot of
disinformation about the integrity of
these elections with the baseless claims
as you say by donald trump
of fraud how do you think the democrats
plan
to combat these claims that the
elections are fraudulent and to restore
faith in the democratic system
well they have been very confident
dealing with the situation in the first
place they have already
stressed look we had international
election observers of the oecd they made
very clear
time and time again we also interviewed
them here
at dwr colleagues in dw's washington
bureau
and they time and time stressed that the
election in the united states was
absolutely fine there was no
uh there's no evidence for any rigged
election for all the claims that donald
trump has been making he and his team
with his lawyer rudy giuliani with his
son eric trump and he himself
countless emails that have been
spreading and sending out talking about
ballots that were burned
ballots that suddenly showed up as he
said after election day and also
including the
claim that um that ballots were cast
after election day
well he has to prove he and his team
they have to prove all of this
and as it looks like and that's also
what we're hearing from some members of
the republican party already there is no
proof for that
and there's hardly any evidence at all
for any
election for any um election
interference in that sense
and so we will have to see how that goes
down with the courts or if donald trump
even at some point
uh changes it might it doesn't look like
it at all at this point
all right oliver's alex standing by for
us in wilmington wilmington delaware
the hometown of joe biden now if you're
just joining us of course we are
declaring that democratic candidate joe
biden has won
the u.s presidential election after
stealing victory in the battleground
state of pennsylvania that's after major
u.s tv networks
and the associated press have called the
race in his favor
i'm going to cross back now to
sumisomosganda in washington dc
to get the latest and find out what has
trump been saying about
this we just heard
clear that president trump says that he
will not concede and he's promised
unspecified legal challenges uh
i should tell you that president trump
is actually not in the white house right
now he's been
out in virginia on his golf course he
left earlier this morning the white
house to head out there
uh he had been in the white house the
last few days and and left a bit earlier
this morning in his motorcade
and so he said from there that he is not
conceding and promising these legal
challenges we also saw him tweet claire
earlier this morning precisely this
message
uh again uh unsubstantiated claims a
voter fraud of illegal voting
and he said you know a few hours ago on
twitter i won this election
by a lot so president trump here is
referring again to these legal
challenges that his team has launched
in a number of these key battleground
states where they're still
tallying votes states like pennsylvania
uh states like michigan and also
in georgia and what we have to keep in
mind however is that the majority
of these legal challenges that his team
has launched to get
vote counting stopped also to get some
of the ballots that have been received
by mail
invalidated that they have been rejected
by judges in those states
because there has been no proof of
widespread voter fraud always as we just
heard from oliver again we have to
reinforce that
and and so when president trump is
referring to these legal challenges
he is presumably talking about pushing
these challenges forward and yet there
has been no success
for his team until this point on that
front so we'll have to see what their
strategy
is going forward with these legal
challenges because they haven't been
successful
it could be that they might try a new
strategy but the president as we said
claire
not conceding at this hour saying he
will continue his legal fight
right the trump campaign not not backing
down that's hardly surprising given the
messaging that we've seen from the
president and his team
in the months leading up to the election
and in the days
since tuesday but sumi are there other
avenues that the president could pursue
to really challenge
this result
well what we've heard the president say
is that he will take this directly to
the supreme court that those were his
words that he believes the supreme court
itself should
decide this election the reality however
claire is that there has to be some sort
of legal basis for the supreme court to
weigh in
if it were to do so and that legal basis
would have to be the following that
president trump's team
would have to to show some sort of proof
that there has been
voter fraud that there have been massive
errors something that would give
courts a reason to take up these legal
challenges and until now that has
not been the case and those would be his
avenues so it does look like the window
is closing in
if you will on on president trump and so
it's not clear what
his legal strategy would be and indeed
we saw some reports yesterday
that president trump's legal team is
wondering
what they will do and the president
himself apparently is not happy with his
lawyers because they feel like he's not
they're not fighting hard enough for him
but i just have to say once more
it doesn't appear to be there doesn't
appear to be any avenue here for the
president to challenge these
unless unless they're they are able to
locate and identify
actual claims of fraud which we have not
seen until now
all right sumisomos ganda in washington
d.c thank you so much
we want to bring you some live pictures
now from outside the white house in
washington d.c
in trump's last months in office there
you say he's out golfing now but let's
take a look at what
uh what americans how americans are
turning out in response to that news
see if you can bring up some pictures
there
there you have it look at that crowd
american flags waving protesters out in
the street
recording this moment surely a historic
election
one for the history books
you can see those signs up on that fence
that was erected outside of the white
house that's also something we've never
seen in history a sitting president
build walls around the white house ahead
of election an election
to show that they are afraid of the mass
movements of people outside
and worried about what would happen in
the aftermath what we're seeing now
looks like a joyous crowd um we'll be
bringing you more
live updates on this story of course
throughout the night if you are just
joining us joe biden has been projected
to win the us
presidency so with 99 of the votes in
biden won 49.7 of those votes
trump won 49.2 and with his victory in
pennsylvania joe biden
has passed the threshold of 270
electoral college votes
needed to win the presidency
well stacy what are we to make of all
this well i mean
maya angelou the american poet and civil
rights activist said when somebody shows
you who they are
believe them donald trump has shown us
who he is for the past four years
he has been divisive he thrives on chaos
and he's back at it again the very fact
that he is
trying to claw away at democracy as an
american president is beyond disgusting
and are we going to see an end to that
kind of behavior with joe biden in
office is this going to be
more of a traditional presidency that
the world has become accustomed to from
the united states
i believe so i mean if past is prolonged
this has been how he's
run his entire career as a politician
reaching across the aisle his best
friend was john
john mccain he worked well with mitch
mcconnell even though they have very
different views when it comes to policy
and he's repeatedly said again and again
that if he is
was elected president that he'd be the
president for both
red states and blue spit states and he
would legislate for people
who whether they voted for him or not
that he would try to bring the country
together
and like i said it's a shame that the
president
can't follow his lead and all of the uh
in all of american history there's never
been a president
who has not been able to first concede
and second try to speak to his
supporters
to thank them for what they've done to
assure them that
you know policies will still try to be
in place because they're there there are
senate people there are
house people that are from the
republican party and
try to say you know look this guy is the
president of the united states we are a
unified country
he has not done that at all this is
unprecedented that's right and if you
remember the last time that a sitting
president was beaten by his challenger
was all the way back in 1992 that's
almost 30 years ago if i'm doing my mass
correction
and that was george w bush losing
against
bill clinton and you know after he lost
he came out made a concession speech
and basically said look my can my
opponent ran a great race
um but now it is time to unite behind
him because he is the president
of the country and as you say we did see
that in biden's speeches that he's been
making this week and asking for patience
he said that he wants to be a president
not just for democrats
i but what you're touching on is really
the key question here
is how biden can really have an
effective presidency
given how deeply divided the country is
given how this misinformation
and how trump supporters have come to
load the democrats and vice versa in the
united states
you mentioned that biden does have a
good relationship with some
republican lawmakers sometimes to his
own detriment sometime to his own
household just because you know
democrats they really want
somebody who will fight for them wholly
and focus solely on what
their policy initiatives are and
biden throughout his career has been
willing to compromise
the big c word and and so
yeah so he's taken some hits for for
doing that
but i just have to say that aside from
the trump
circus that this is a monumental
occasion
and that senator kamala harris vice
president-elect
is the first woman to be in the white
house and with all of what's happening
with trump
i think that we need to take time to
acknowledge what is happening here this
is historic
all of those little brown girls who felt
like there was like this glass ceiling
not just in politics but in regular life
now have a role model and representation
matters
she is the first woman the first woman
of color af
black and south asian descent we need to
honor that and respect that there are so
many people
who marched on the streets who were
fighting for
the rights of black people still in 2020
and we're not going to get any recourse
from president donald trump
and now they see and feel they have a
chance with joe biden
and that needs to be recognized the fact
that trump cannot be a gracious loser
he wasn't a gracious winner but the fact
that he is focusing more on himself
instead of the institution of democracy
what can you say about that that's right
it is a historic day for the california
senator
now vice president-elect kamala harris
who is also just a heartbeat
away from the presidency over the next
four years and basically they've been
setting the stage
for a potential run by her in the future
we'll be back with you in four
or eight years time for more on that but
stacy thanks so much i went across now
over back to our correspondent
oliver zalet who is in wilmington
delaware oliver have we had any word
from what biden's team has to say on all
this
well the biden team came out with a
statement just a little while ago and
really reiterating uh
biden's position that he wants to unite
and to heal the nation
he wrote its time to put anger and the
harsh rhetoric of the recent months
and weeks aside and of the last four
years of course of the
trump administration and that is what he
was elected for that is
how he uh that is his major argument
basically that he put forward in his
election campaign
and he might be the right person to
unite the nation he has
a lot of credibility among blue-collar
voters he grew up
here in wilmington born in scranton
pennsylvania an industrial
region and he even experienced
experienced poverty in his childhood
so that gives him that sort of
credibility that was also
necessary to win back those important
swing states of wisconsin michigan now
also pennsylvania
and with that credibility that he has
and with that uh
with that acceptance among not only uh
liberals but also
the working class he might really be the
one that is actually able to now to
unite and heal the country as he
promised
all right so a lot of talk about joe
biden being able to reach across the
aisle
and connect with republicans who may not
have may not have given such a
sympathetic year to some of the other
people who are running
for president as a democrat but oliver i
want to ask you too
do you think joe biden is really able to
reach
out to the working class which is
traditionally the stronghold of the
democratic policy because we did see so
many people that one might assume would
traditionally be democratic voters
vote for trump even in this election
after four years of a trump presidency
well he certainly has a lot of plans to
help specifically this group there's a
minimum salary of 15 dollars that he's
planning to
impose um he wants a a free
uh he wants free uh college tuition for
those who earn less than 125 000 per
year
he also wants to help the americans with
um with
with health care so there's a lot of
plans but of course
in the end he knows that he needs the
support of the senate and he needs
control of the senate with the
democratic party and that's everything
but sure at this moment
so it might be a very challenging
presidency in spite of his victory
we'll have to see we'll have to watch
out for the senate we will also have to
watch out
for all the challenges uh else that he's
facing and we're
just looking at the pandemic that we're
seeing record numbers here right now
again
all right oliver zalat in wilmington
thank you very much for that i want to
cross back
over now it to pennsylvania that's the
big that was the big prize that has
appeared to push biden over the edge
toward the presidency to become
president-elect of the united states
i hear that honking again stefan what's
the mood like
oh well i'm engulfed in a car horn
honking symphony here
passing us by and i would love to for my
cameraman to just show you to the side
of us he's here we're not alone here
there's a convention center behind me
and there are colleagues from cnn and
other networks right next to us and
we're all doing the same
there's the young crowd predominantly
young crown the last few minutes
actually
um moving to around the corner of this
building this is what's the scene where
we had
in the last few days last two or three
days
this standoff between pro count the vote
biden harry supporters and trump
supporters so they're all heading there
and this will be
i think this will be more of a party
mode
there festival mode around the corner
and we're gonna
head there so bottom line is and this is
what i'm trying to say here is that
uh at least this is a first impression
people in philadelphia
who have in my opinion
been very sure that this would be the
outcome anyway this is a heavily
democratic
county and city here they are very happy
about the news of course that
joe biden is now called or declared
president-elect and will be the 46th
president of the united states
however there is scheduled a a protest
in harrisburg at the capital of
pe of pennsylvania by trump supporters a
steal the vote or
anti-steal the vote protest i have no
information so far if this actually
materializes right now
but as my esteemed colleagues pointed
out
trump the trump administration the
president himself and his supporters
do not show any sign of giving up or or
trying to
um if not maybe hinder the process go to
the courts do
through whatever legal actions fact of
the matter is that behind me in this
building
the last batch of data released three
thousand and something votes counted
and these are male in ballots counted
put
joe biden statistically and
mathematically over the top there is no
way
experts statisticians math math
people who are much better in math than
i am uh think now that
the president could make up the ground
here in the vote count even if he gets
50 55 60 of any other vote count
from now on through the next few days
because next few days
don't forget they still still keep
counting not just here but everywhere in
the country and every other state and of
course in the counties around here in
pennsylvania
also allegheny county towards
pittsburgh in the surrounding counties
montgomery is that right here
and so on so count is going on and
nobody expects for pennsylvania
uh the results to change dramatically
and this is exactly the reason why
you hear a lot of honking and
celebrating here and
why all the networks here domestic
networks and ap as we pointed out
called this election in favor of
joe biden that's right and they've been
waiting with a baited breath for the
last four days as
have has everyone around the world
stephen simon's in
pennsylvania thank you so much for that
i'm going to bring you those
latest numbers from pennsylvania that
pushed joe biden over the edge
with a 99 of the votes in biden has won
49.7 of those votes
trump won 49.2 now with pennsylvania
joe biden has passed the threshold of
270 electoral college votes
needed to win the presidency